Joker I don't know safe place Batman got
his we going thought I heard something
hey where's cook
you
Tim where are you got your call what's
this about Joker's got my father
maybe we should call Batman no Joker
specifically said he'd killed him in
Batman showed up did anything happen to
him I don't know what I do don't worry
barn you got this it's gonna be all
right how can you be so sure well for
one Robin's a good luck boys Scotty
No
max
there's a terminal by the door what are
you waiting for I'll leave the hacking
to the computer whiz
not even a challenge hey kitty great
work I know our Daisy tough though the
very good time I'm really to witness for
the benefit of the family hey cobijas
Papa bird lovingly pushing you from the
net spread that girl let's do this after
you
this place never opened did it never got
a permit an oil baron built it for his
five-year-old daughter when she died he
just scared in the project fell apart
now the Joker's turned it into his
personal playpen watch it Batgirl sniper
wait here I'll take care of him hold on
Robin I got this
how'd you get so good with computers
well first of those 10 yeah not now
I've got a hostage I see him wait here
I'll take care of this easy cowboy let's
work together I'll distract a sniper
then we'll take down the hinchman sounds
like a plan
on your signal
that was easy this isn't over yet focus
Robin always see it used to be simple I
blow things up he shows up start all
over again they ambushed us we didn't
see him coming I don't know what he's
planning but Gordon he's in trouble
he'll be okay I'll make sure that now
there's you two knuckleheads spoiling my
game my game not Robyn RPG I see it
that girl you okay I'm fine just a few
scratches how's the hostage a little
shaken up but he's okay he says the
trocar ambush them at GCPD he's got
other hostages great where are you in
the park I'll wait for you here no I'll
find high ground to scan for more
hostages you see if you can locate the
Joker
she's here
cuz I'm is voice and that's white poodle
this shouldn't be a problem
you